okay now you can see I've got this this
copy here I probably come in here now
really this part over here also doesn't
come up that much either
like we're not certainly going to get
these in triangles or anything like that
which is the same as we've Pythagoras so
the first place you should highlight
this on your diagram the first place
that most people would go is to restrict
your acute angles right to say not to
platitude we really want those right
they come up all the time
so they're kind of like yeah don't
choose those you're crazy right they're
so useful to us so we definitely want
from an author plan - okay however as
you just noticed because what restricts
us is turning points or our success is
turning point being that you could get
this half you get this bit it's comes
along for free it doesn't present any
problems - giving you an inverse
function it it doesn't use your the
inverse relation by accident unlike say
say this Pacquiao
so this part I've got this these obtuse
angles they would be nice wouldn't they
they would be nice but you can't get
them without causing a problem without
getting a relation so therefore here is
what we're going to choose we're going
to define so y cosine X we must function
right but if we restrict y equals sine X
nice margin to pilot
so could you say the name was again
where were you talking about yes that's
true yeah you would but so I could I
could choose it from anywhere I like but
man if I choose this pot I lose the
acute angles yeah right and here's the
important thing right if I know of a
single reference ankle right I've
definitely cute to be obtuse and I think
they're from the equivalent of two
cities I can't go in either direction
but why go from a hotter angle to work
we should be easier more common angle
isn't a better stuff from this one and
then say I can get all of the related
angles and from that one which you've
already been doing for a long time which
all stations essential and so on so let
me say this guy here with a restricted
domain this has an inverse function and
we're going to define that we defined
that as sine inverse okay now please
don't remember what we talked about this
morning and yesterday afternoon but
algebraically the thing you can say
about an inverse function if it really
is the inverse function is that taking
the inverse of the original function
should hand you back what should hand
you back the original number right and
you could also do any reverse just find
advice okay however look carefully
right-side inverse of sine X does it
fully this think about it don't shadow
minutes just yet sine inverse of sine X
will it always change you back X now
it's clear sometimes it will right let's
just do a quick example we know say sine
of 0 sine of 0 is 0 sine inverse of 0
it's gonna say well which angle in this
red dotted domain has a value of 0 up
and down here and the answer is it's
that one it's okay right
in fact any of these angles in here
they're fine it'll
change you back the angle that you came
from right it'll do this right but you
calculator calculator out if you were
outside that domain you're in trouble on
cheese you're in trouble you don't write
this part but I do watch sheets you
[ __ ] joke that later if you for
example do sine inverse of sine hmm
let's go for we already said 3 PI over 2
that's outside the domain okay now just
be careful with your brackets sign a
mess of a sign to clinch it and don't
forget I hope you're in Raymond's what
did it tell you hey you got a decimal
right okay so if you're getting this I
know it's a yucky decimal but it ought
to be a yucky decimal you should start
to recognize why got your decimal is it
forest I'm expecting an angle aunt I'm
expecting the angle out of this right
like it would usually handing back an
angle if I double this it looks like I
get 3.14 okay so what's happened what
has happened it's handed me back rather
than the angle I started with the only
angles it has to choose from are the
ones I restricted it to right it's like
look I said this this outside well now
it doesn't exist to you in wall sine
inverse all it can ever hand back to you
is something within this domain okay so
that's why I hand to you look he's state
plan too right so your calculator says I
know what sine three plan to is it's
negative one and then it goes to the
next step
sine inverse of maybe what which angle
in my domain will give me negative 1
when I take the name on the answer this
area's right there that's the only one I
thought do you see this causes a bit of
a problem okay now remember we said you
can do this you can also do it in the
reverse
right so what would happen if we did say
sine of sine inverse of three plan - you
have a calculator there now type it into
don't yet keyboard think about for a
second before unity goes okay we saw
this happen now I want you to predict I
want you to predict if we know something
is a bit funky here right because we've
mucked around with it what are you going
to expect to come out are you gonna take
- plan - are you going to take something
else and of course it tells you it tells
you go home why you make me do these
things from all right now why the
question of course is why you have to go
up two K blocks are II that visa
kindness to begin your phone again and
just so you kept its outside the domain
here which means it's outside the range
of this yes good okay so you can you see
what happens right it's just like this
right what's gonna happen if you say to
your calculator
hey especially if you have a not 100 pay
you if you say something like this right
it's gonna tell you that era which is
way of saying you're not saying the
domain this doesn't make sense okay just
the same thing here now a question for
you I'm not gonna do it right now it
comes up in a later exercise what would
this look like like is in you you know
what this looks like this graph you know
what this looks like okay what do the
graphs of each of these functions appear
to apply sine inverse of sine X and sine
of signing discotheques they're
interesting I'll let you have them back
we will deal with that later on okay but
you there's no reason why you can't
think about it now okay